en allant chercher plus d'argent chez
les mieux nantis en fermant des
échappatoires fiscaux on va pouvoir
aller chercher des revenus significatifs
[Musique]
pour aller chercher de l'argent justin
trudeau promet de lutter contre les
échappatoires fiscales de taxer le luxe
comme les voitures les bateaux de plus
de 5000 $ et taxer les géants du web
selon lui les trois mesures devrait
rapporter 3 milliards de dollars dès le
prochain budget mais selon le directeur
parlementaire du budget selon elle
certains pour les trois mesures le
directeur parlementaire du budget dit
que l'évaluation comportent un degré
d'incertitude élevé seulement au sujet
des mesures pour lutter contre des
échappatoires fiscales
il ajoute les sociétés qui s'adonnent à
une planification fiscale agressive
pourrait tenter d'employer de nouveaux
stratagèmes d'évitement bref peut-être
que c'est possible d'aller chercher les
3 milliards de dollars mais pour y
arriver il faudrait que les entreprises
comme les géants du web accepte de se
plier aux règles du jeu sans chercher à
les éviter
ce qui est loin d'être certaine